Computer system security has assumed enormous importance in the connected world
that we live in today. Indeed, there are courses offered just on the topic of
computer system security. And universities, including
Georgia Tech, offer an entire Master's degree
program on information security. In this course module our goal is to get
an introduction to the terminologies in
computer system security that we should be
familiar with as operating system designers. Using
a case study we'll also learn Cryptographic
techniques that can be used as a tool by an operating system designer
to provide authentication in a distributed manner.
We'll start this module with a discussion
of the terminologies first articulated by Jerome Solser. You'll be
amazed at how computer visionaries thought of issues
with information security, even before computers were connected to one another.